hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar from research to
routine developing and delivering
multiplex protein mass spectrometry
based tests of clinical utility I am
Judy oracle's laberd's and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website a provider of virtual
events and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning and made
possible by an open educational grant
from agilent technologies agilent
technologies has said no input in the
selection of speakers content or mode of
presentation let's get started you can
post questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
Q&A box which will open when you click
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window questions
will be answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green to an A button at lower left this
is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the C e button located in the bottom
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits I now present today's speaker
dr. Stephen Pennington Steve is
professor of proteomics at University
College Dublin Ireland a chemist
Imperial College London and PhD
biochemist University of Cambridge by
training through engagement in a series
of collaborations and international
consortium his current biomedical
proteomics research is directed to the
discovery and development of protein
biomarkers ongoing projects are focused
on a mass spectrometry based measurement
and evaluation of protein biomarkers in
oncology and inflammatory disease
to progress them to future clinical
diagnostic utility Steve's team is also
investigating the mechanisms of disease
progression focusing on prostate cancer
and psoriatic arthritis Steve is highly
energetic and enthusiastic with an
innovative open and inclusive approach
to his work he has given over 200
invited presentations at international
events published over 80 scientific
papers edited and contributed to several
books including editing one of the first
books on proteomics that was translated
into Chinese and Japanese Steve has held
roles as a committee member in the
British society for proteome research
currently vice president and the
European proteomics association he
served as the lead organizer of the
recent annual World Congress of the
human proteome organization Hugh Poe
held in Dublin recently Steve founded
the UCD spin-out company at arose in
December 2016 to support the delivery of
OSI projects to clinical use OSI
projects is a prostate cancer blood
based biomarker test that has the
capability to distinguish patients with
organ confined and non organ confined
disease the test will help inform men
diagnosed with prostate cancer whether
they should go on or stay on active
surveillance the Itoro s-- team has the
expertise and experience to deliver this
and other multiplex protein biomarker
tests to market doctor Pennington will
now begin his presentation thank you
Judy for that very kind introduction and
to colleagues in libraries and Agilent
for making this webinar possible as
we've heard I'm going to talk about
taking biomarkers from research to
routine and how we might do that by
developing and delivering multiplexed
protein mass spectrometry based tests of
clinical utility and I've just put up
this light now to acknowledge the
funding agencies that have supported the
work that we've been doing from the
Health Research Board and the Irish
Cancer Society to more recently
Enterprise Ireland and I just you've
heard the how I began life as a chemist
as a chemist at Imperial College there
were two things that that really put me
off continuing as a chemist they were
NMR and mass spectrometry and I was
taught mass spectrometry by one of the
world leading experts at the time an
individual called herb Morris who'd
invented his own technique of mass
spectrometry he'd used that technique of
mass spectrometry to work with John
Hughes to identify the ink Esalen
pentapeptides and that was a paper that
they published in nature in 1975 so
having decided that I couldn't get to
grips with mass spectrometry and NMR I
then went on to do biochemistry at
Imperial where I got involved in
separating proteins by using 2d gels so
you can imagine my surprise and slight
dismay in the early to mid-90s when it
became apparent that if we were going to
study proteins and and separate them by
2d gels mass spectrometry was going to
be essential for that for their
identification and so as we've already
heard I then had the opportunity to edit
a book on proteomics which was one of
the first groups on proteomics in the
intervening over 20 years now we've been
trying to use proteomics to understand
disease mechanisms and identify disease
markers and increasingly like many
others I got frustrated frustrated at
our lack of success of converting those
those mechanisms my markers to something
of clinical utility particularly in the
field of bio markers that frustration
hasn't been just my own it's been shared
by others and recently the MRC subjected
undertook a review of biomarker progress
not just protein biomarkers but DNA and
other molecules and so that review was a
resistor I think one of the
opportunities that we thought we had
were to try and increase our success was
to collaborate to go from local work to
global collaboration and we were part of
one of the first global action plans
that Movember a funding agency that that
supports men's health research initiated
a number of years ago so I think that
whilst undoubtedly collaboration can
make a major impact more recently we've
been focused on on how we might convert
some of the research discoveries that
we've made into things of
of utility and for the purposes of doing
that then as we've heard I founded the
company of Shiraz so that company was
founded in 2014 just a few years ago and
was officially spun out of the
university just at the end of last year
December 2016 with a focus on taking
routine or making routine some of the
tests that we developed in the research
arena and and applying those for
clinical utility a clinical utility can
look like this this is a form from a
hospital in Dublin taken in the form
taken in 2006 and what it shows is a
form in which a clinician will take a
number of boxes to have a number of
tests performed to try and understand
better the patient's current diagnostic
situation and so in this case a tick
boxes is picked a blood sample is drawn
that blood sample is then taken to the
laboratory and then in the laboratory
the tests performed and the results went
back to the clinician such that he or
she is a better able to make a decision
for the patient this is that form in
2016 if we return to the same hospital
in 2000 2006 even returned to the same
hospital in 2016 10 years on you'll see
that the form looks different and indeed
it is different because two Hospital
departments have merged and they put
both of their tests on one form there's
been a change of font and a change of
color but the reality is that there are
no new biomarkers there are no new tests
on that form so over the 10 years in
which we've been excited about devant in
genomics and proteomics and metabolomics
there are no new tick boxes on these
forms that have enabled clinicians to
make better informed decisions about
their patients we can see in the bottom
right here that a number of the tests
are for proteins in blood and including
for example PSA and AFP that was ticked
on ticked on this form and those are
proteins in blood that indicate whether
a patient may have a particular cancer
for AFP it's a path of cellular
carcinoma and for PSA it's prostate
cancer
so I suppose in the years that have been
intervening and as part of our
frustration we've been asking ourselves
the question of whether the protein
biomarkers that we discover will ever be
useful and if that's going to be the
case then how we will proceed to getting
them to be useful and what I've done
here is that it outlined the process
that we use for going through biomarker
discovery and assay development and and
then subsequently confirmation and
evaluation and validation and there's
nothing new on this slide this just
shows a version of a process that many
people have adopted to try to get to
biomarkers that may be of clinical value
of course the end point of all of this
is a biomarker that will be that will
result in a clinical test and so and I'm
just trying to draw an arrow here just
to show and highlight that that's a
clinical test that will be the output of
all of all of this work I've separated
this process into a number of discrete
phases in which we begin with discovery
to identify some protein biomarker
candidates we can confirm those protein
biomarker candidates by developing an
assay to them and increasingly now we
realized that not individual proteins
will form a biomarker but it may be a
panel of multiple proteins and so having
developed assays to measure a panel of
proteins we can evaluate the performance
of that panel of proteins and ultimately
have a clinical test I have drawn the
analogy that this is a bit like climbing
Everest that we go through the process
in multiple stages often you know
reaching camp one and then having to
decline again to to base camp so that we
can react lima ties eventually we
progress through camp one two three and
four and ultimately reach the summit of
Everest and of course when we get to
Everest we can view the top of the world
so we've begun at Basecamp and even got
maybe two camp one or two and the result
of that has been a whole series of
biomarker discovery projects in a in a
range of different disease
which we've attempted to identify
biomarkers from tissues or cells from
serum various biological fluids and the
result of all of that work really has
been summarized in a recent review back
in 2011 in which job George post
described all of this is biomarker
futility biomarker futility because the
omics haven't delivered any new
biomarkers to the clinic and George post
identified what he thought were a number
of reasons as to why that's the case
including the fact that we were using or
have been using poor specimens that
we've had a fragmented approach to the
way that and a fragmented approach to
the way that we do this so I'm getting a
little carried away with the animations
there um so there's no doubt that the
reasons that George has identified have
indeed prevented us from getting to
effectively to the to the Everest of
biomarker discovery because the Everest
of biomarker discovery would be a new
clinical test protein biomarkers
discovered in our laboratory that were
now incorporated into clinical tests
that was used by patients for four four
five sorry by physicians for patient
benefit of course we'd ideally be at the
peak of the summit of Everest and so I
have to confess that I'd like to reach
the new producer new clinical test
effectively to reach this this Everest
and there's a little bit of sibling
rivalry going on here because I have a
younger sister who has reached the
summit of Everest twice the real Everest
not the biomarker Everest and she's done
that twice she's the only UK woman to
summited Everest twice and I'd really as
I say in a sense of sibling rivalry like
to be able to beat her by summiting the
biomarker equivalent of every studies to
develop a a new clinical test and if
we're going to do that you could
obviously ask yourself how are we going
to be able to do it can we discover
biomarkers and develop them into new
tests of clinical utility and value and
many of the challenges associated with
doing that are really well rehearsed now
and as well as in the in the post review
that I've just mentioned there there are
a number of articles that have survived
outline
some of the challenges faced in taking a
biomarker that's been discovered and
converting it to a new clinical test so
there are undoubtedly very many
challenges in that process and that
perhaps in part explains why very few if
any have reached the the Everest of
biomarker discovery and development so
you can imagine my surprise a few years
ago when at a biomarker meeting a young
bright-eyed consultant Dean Griffith
said actually to get a biomarker to
clinical YouTube utility is simple he
said all that you need to do is identify
a need find the solution and then scale
it and of course in those terms it is
very straightforward and those are just
the discrete steps that you need to go
through and I suppose back in 2014 when
I first heard this that got us thinking
to what we really need to do is to begin
the process at the end that is that we
need to identify the clinical test that
we would wish to develop and then begin
the process of discovery and so just to
reiterate that's to identify the
clinical need and a clinical test that
will address that need and then begin
the discovery process and I suppose
since around 2012 2014 when we were
formulating these ideas that's when we
began studies in to disease areas and I
just want to illustrate one of those
disease areas and really begin by
illustrating that beginning at the end
process and so the disease area is
prostate cancer so I'm sure many will
many of you be aware of the the impact
that prostate cancer has but what you
may not be aware is that one in six men
get diagnosed with prostate cancer at
some time in their lives this is in the
Western underdeveloped world so in
Ireland which is a small country that's
over three and a half thousand men a
year in the UK it's over thirty thousand
men in Europe it's close on half a
million men every year get diagnosed
with prostate cancer and that diagnosis
is made initially on the basis of a
protein PSA that's found in blood and so
PSA is a small protein found in blood
and an elevated level of that protein is
suggestive of prostate cancer once it's
found to be elevated the clinician then
will perform a digital rectal exam a D
re and the d re is what it really says
on the tin that's where a glove digit is
inserted into the rectum and the and the
prostate gland palpated for any
abnormalities
if abnormalities are felt then the the
patient is then subjected to a biopsy
and the biopsy is where a needle biopsy
needle is inserted into the prostate
guided by ultrasound and most commonly
until fairly recently this was done by
was transparent and transitory
transrectal more recently it's trans
peritoneal the trans rectal biopsy is
carry with them a risk of infection and
so the patient very often will have to
have prophylactic antibiotics and
because it is so painful we'll have to
have significant anesthesia before the
biopsy procedure once the biopsy tissue
is removed it's then section and scored
by an expert pathologist according to a
Gleason grading system from one to five
so armed with an elevated PSA an
abnormal D re and a Gleason score of the
tissue the clinician is able to make a
diagnosis of the disease so if you
imagine for example this is a young man
with his back to us it's hairy young
he's in his mid-40s he has a routine
health check because although there's
nothing wrong with him his his work
suggests that it would be a good idea
for him to either routine health check
and he does that and it comes back that
his PSA is elevated it's actually quite
elevated it's at twelve point two
nanograms per mil where the threshold
for suggestive of possible prostate
cancer is four nanograms per mil
subsequently then Harry has a digital
rectal exam and that comes back as being
slightly abnormal subsequently after
this then he has a biopsy and if biopsy
comes back as Gleason three plus four
that's two regions have been scored and
that's a Gleason seven the result of
this is unambiguous Harry has
de cáncer so recall a little while ago
berry was Perry was asymptomatic but
just went for a routine test and now a
week later it's absolutely clear that he
has prostate cancer what to do next is
determined by Harry's risk score in his
case he's between low and intermediate
risk regardless of whether he's in
Europe or America and that will then
determine why it will follow his his
diagnosis and what follows his diagnosis
is that he clearly has to make with his
clinician a very significant and it's a
life-changing decision the decision is
to either have active and invasive
treatment of the disease that is a
radical prostatectomy where the prostate
gland is removed or radiation treatment
where the prostate will be treated in
situation both of those treatments carry
with them significant comorbidities
Harry's likely to experience urinary
dysfunction and bowel dysfunction as
well as erectile dysfunction all of
which will have a major impact on his
quality of life
he's also likely to experience the side
effects of hormone therapy which
includes some feminization the third
option that Harry might have would be to
go on an active active surveillance
that's where the disease is monitored
until it's felt that treatment would be
absolutely necessary an active
surveillance will involve repeat PSA
testing some imaging of the prostate
potentially and possibly repeat biopsies
the main corporate comorbidity
associated with active surveillance is
one of anxiety for Harry to have to live
with knowing that he has prostate cancer
and so he's likely to come under
significant external pressure to have
his tumor treated until very recently it
was really the majority of men with
Harry's kind of diagnosis of prostate
cancer with those molecular and clinical
features would have had the first two
options they would have had either a
radical prostatectomy or radiation
treatment however at the end of last
year published in New England Journal of
Medicine was a paper that showed the
outcome of a clinic
trial in which over 500 men were
randomized to those three treatment
options the treatment options being
radical prostatectomy radiotherapy or
active surveillance and those men were
followed for ten years and ten years
later it became apparent that there is
no difference in deaths from prostate
cancer among the three groups so that
means that two thirds of the men had
this invasive treatment that has
significant life affecting comorbidities
without it having any impact on their
death from prostate cancer and that's
led to the realization that there is
massive over treatment of men with
prostate cancer and the realization also
that that less is more that for those
men who are chosen well active
surveillance is perfectly safe indeed it
would be the preferred option because
the quality of life is significantly
improved for men who don't have those
invasive treatments however the current
tools for selecting which patients to go
on on active surveillance are inadequate
and imprecise and indeed there are no
minimally invasive blood tests that
support the decision to go on and stay
on active surveillance because it's
recognized that men who have multiple
biopsies because they're so painful so
uncomfortable and actually carry with
them significant risks themselves that
most men will choose after a number of
biopsies to then just have one of those
active treatments there are also
significant it's significant
imprecisions associated with the biopsy
assessment process so a number of years
ago we undertook a road map of
decision-making as men are treated with
prostate cancer and the urologist that
we work with suggested that this second
question of knowing whether the disease
is organ confined or non or would
confined would be a significant question
to be able to answer and would help in
the process of making decisions for men
diagnosed with prostate cancer so just
the next slide just illustrates that but
in organ confined disease the tumor
allow me just to highlight
the tumor is resident within the
prostate
obviously grows over time in this case
it may as is often the case with
prostate cancer have multiple foci until
eventually it becomes non organ confined
that is that it spreads into the seminal
vesicles and into the systemic blood
system so the difference then between an
organ can find disease verses and non
organ can find diseases that in the case
of the non organ can find disease it's
likely to become ultimately metastatic
and be life-threatening whereas organ
confine disease will never be
life-threatening so and with that piece
of information and that desire we began
the discovery process and in this case
the discovery process began with taking
serum samples from men who either had
organ confin'd disease or non organ
confined disease and subjecting that to
standard label-free lc/ms proteomics
discovery and in this proteomics
discovery workflow we took the serum
samples depleted them of abundant
proteins digested the proteins with
trypsin cleaned them up put them onto
mass spectrometers in this case q eggs
active and cute off mass spectrometers
and undertook qualitative and
quantitative analysis and then used a
series of statistical tools in a range
of software software's available to
identify proteins that would potentially
discriminate between organ confined and
non-urban confined disease and through
this process we identified a series of
candidates and these candidates were
also then supplemented with discovery
experiments that we did by gels and by
reviewing the literature so that
ultimately we ended up with 64 candidate
proteins so these are proteins that may
discriminate between organ confined and
non organ confined disease now in the
past under with a biomarker candidate
like this we would have had to have
selected one or two of the best
candidate proteins and progress them
through the pipeline that I showed
earlier what we have now been able to do
with the advent of multiple reaction
monitoring is not develop assays to a
single of those proteins but to develop
us
potentially to all of the proteins so
multiple monitoring mass spectrometry
mrn multiple reaction monitoring is a
process in which we can target the
measurement of specific proteins and so
just to outline the process if in a
mixture of proteins there's a protein of
interest that we that we wish to be able
to measure we can identify peptides that
for that protein that are target
proteins peptides that we're going to
measure and these peptides have unique
mastercharge
the master charge ratio of the peptides
derived from this protein as such that
the peptides can only have ever come
from our protein of interest and not
from the other of other proteins in the
complex mixture so having identified
tryptic peptides that are unique to the
protein of interest we then you measure
these in a triple quadra mass
spectrometer so depicted below is a
triple quad mass spectrometer in which
all of the peptides all of the ionized
peptides are move into the first
quadrupole and we select a mass filter
in that first quadrupole that only
allows the peptide of mass-to-charge
ratio event of interest to us through
into the second quadrupole the second
quadrupole acts as a collision cell and
so that peptide iron is fragmented and
of course if the peptide is the peptide
we think it is we know the masses of the
fragments that are generated and so in
the third quadrupole we can select a
filter that will only allow fragments of
a size that we predetermine to reach
ultimately reach the detector and so
what we can see here is a retention time
trace showing in this case the intensity
of the fragment that is of the highest
intensity from our peptide if we want to
be sure that the peptide that we have
think we're measuring is indeed that
peptide from this complex mixture we can
of course in the third quadrupole select
a second fragment time
mass of interest and measure
the intensity of that fragment time and
subsequently a third fragment time of
interest and measure the intensity of
that fragment eyes and we can keep doing
that process for as many fragment ions
as we wish to use to confirm the
identity of the original peptide so this
method one the method of the year from
nature a number of years ago and at the
time I wasn't even aware that nature ran
a method of the Year competition and
there are many good reasons why targeted
proteomics by multiple reaction
monitoring one that particular method
that particular accolade and that's
because it has a dynamic range of over
four orders of magnitude which is it's
probably greater than any other
analytical technique certainly that I'm
aware of but you can multiplex it very
easily and so we routinely measure over
50 proteins per assay it can be
quantitative so by incorporating
peptides of known amount into the assay
you can you can measure the fragment
ions from those peptides and compare
them with the fragment lines of the
peptides of interest the trick of course
is to incorporate peptides that are the
same as the peptide of interest except
that they are isotopically labeled they
may have 15 n carbon or 13 sorry 15 and
nitrogen or 13 C carbon incorporated
into them rather than the natural
isotope triple quad mass spectrometer
can be very robust and many many
occasions these assays can be developed
to Seavey's of less than 10 percent and
I'm going to illustrate that in a moment
however as with many methodologies there
are limitations and in many cases this
approach is not as sensitive as analyzer
and but there are ways that can be there
can be certain that can be used to
circumvent that limitation so just to
reiterate reiterate the method requires
that we identify a measure peptide
that's unique to the protein of interest
and we measure that peptide it's master
charge ratio and fragments of it that
are generate
the mass spectrometer in this case a
triple cord mass spectrometer a very
robust mass spectrometer so we developed
our first multiplex assay in 2006
and and that was an assay to cytochrome
p450s in this case 16 cytochrome p450 is
measured simultaneously in around 30 to
40 minutes so that's like doing 16
quantitative Western blots or
quantitative Eliza's simultaneously on
one individual sample subsequently that
approach has been patented and is now
available as a product from Sigma so
that just don't illustrates I think I
robust these assays can be and we
developed subsequently an assay 248
proteins and published at a few years
later with colleagues from from Agilent
in this case Christine Miller from
Agilent published that paper with us so
over the 10 years that we've been doing
this we've now developed a very robust
mrm workflow in which from a candidate
list we can pet pick peptides and
prioritize those peptides and and we
found that it's very very helpful and go
through this process to use spectrum
mill from from Agilent it's a very
robust approach for identifying peptides
and the peptides that are prioritized by
peptide selector in our hands turned out
to be ultimately very good peptides for
measuring the proteins by mrm initially
we begin an unscheduled analysis of the
peptide to identify retention time and
the reproducibility of our methods and
then once we know the retention time of
the peptide we can target the mass
spectrometer or program the mass
spectrometer to just look for the
peptide that we're interested in at it
during a specific time window and we
call that a scheduled method so then
having a scheduled method to a peptide
of interest we can optimize the method
by optimizing the collision energy and
and and doing that through the analysis
of synthetic pesticides so there are old
series of steps that we can go through
to optimize this workflow so going back
to our 64 candidate proteins that we
discovered that have the potential
discriminate between organ confined
an on organ confined disease we were
able to develop MROs to those 64
candidate proteins in fact it turned out
that we were able to develop mr enter
263 of the 64 candidate proteins for
doing biomarker evaluation and obviously
that targeted approach now is much more
effective than attempting to develop
assays using antibodies to those
individual proteins so we were able to
develop multiplex mrn strategy for
measuring those candidate proteins and
use additional paper patient samples to
evaluate them of course the devil is in
the detail and what I'm showing here is
over 30 biomarker mr ends for some of
those candidate proteins and so these
are really carefully selective and
optimized Mr Ms for those some of those
candidate proteins and I think that this
is perhaps one of the most challenging
parts of this process is developing
really robust assays assays that work in
the particular sample that's being used
and in this case it's a crude serum
sample so now what it highlighted here
is that that using this targeted
approach we can confirm whether the
candidates do indeed increase in from
our discovery cohort of patients and we
can then use the targeted approach this
mrm approach to evaluate the clinical
performance of a panel of proteins and I
would say then move us two steps further
towards developing a clinical test so
we're perhaps reaching camp three on our
climb up Everest to a clinical test when
we did that for the first thirty one of
those candidate proteins and so what
this is showing is the mrm measurements
of those 31 of those candidate proteins
in a different patient sample set we can
measure the area under the curve for
discriminate for their ability to
discriminate organ confined from non
organ confined disease that's all
confined from non organ confined disease
and that produced in a UC of about
around point eight the clinicians
informed us that that was a very
valuable AUC and it was
worth continuing our statisticians
confirmed for us that this wasn't by
random chat so they tested this for
randomness and were able to show that
those AUC values generated could not
have been arrived at by random chance
alone and so on the basis of that the
university filed a patent on those
prostate cancer biomarkers and that was
in December of 2013 we then developed
the assay further and under they say
because said before move that to sixty
three proteins so measuring 63 of the 64
candidate proteins in a separate cohort
of patients again a modest sized cohort
of patients and using a range of
different statistical approaches again
the AUC values were around about point
eight so suppose that's given as
submission confidence that we have
identified some proteins that can
discriminate organ confined from non
organ confined disease and that we may
have a solution to the need that we'd
identified and so the Aleutians solution
in this case is a multiplexed protein
blood test that can discriminate organ
confined from non organ confined disease
that begins by taking a blood sample
making serum the serum being digested
with trypsin and the peptides going onto
a triple quad mass spectrometer to
perform this test and the test then
being used to generate a confinement
score the probability with which the
prostate cancer is confined to the
prostate or has spread beyond it and as
i've indicated the university filed a
patent on that panel of prostate cancer
biomarkers so that's all very well to
have a panel of proteins that bill
seemed to have the ability to
discriminate between organ confines and
non organ confined disease but if it's
going to become a clinical test than
what we have to demonstrate is both the
analytical validity and the clinical
utility of that test and the analytical
validity means that we can perform the
test routinely and robustly sufficiently
robustly then it could be used to
diagnose and make a treatment decision
for a patient and so what we did a
number of years ago was to set up a
small laboratory in which we simply take
samples that are stored in a -
the freezer digests them with trypsin on
a workflow and then put them into a
triple quad mass spectrometer and all
that happens in the laboratory is those
simple steps and everything is done by
standard operating procedures so this
really is to test the analytical
robustness of the methodology we
incorporate into this a lot of quality
control samples and one of the quality
control samples that include is a
peptide mix we call it the TSP a excuse
me the TSP a peptide mix and this just
is measuring the retention time of those
tspa peptides on the chromatography that
precedes the mass spectrometry and we
see routinely that these peptides have a
retention times of less than two and a
half percent and that means that the
peptides eluting this at the same time
on every single occasion and it means
that we can then assess the peak areas
more automat or more robustly and more
automatically and so when we try then to
measure the analytical reproducibility
of the test and this is a busy slide but
essentially what it shows is it shows
four different runs one here a second
here third sorry there's a slight pause
and we get to the tool a third and a
fourth as we move towards the right for
different batches run over four days and
those four batches have in them a number
of QC samples so wherever there's a
shaded box that's where a QC sample has
been run and so now with within those QC
samples we've run a hundred and thirty
patient samples approximately and we
have both sample and analytical replicas
and this really is just to demonstrate
the robustness of the methodology if we
now measure the area of those 16 QC
peptides we can see that the area of all
of the QC peptides the average CV over
160 samples that is 96 hours of mass
spec runtime is around six and a half
percent so that demonstrates the
robustness of these particular assays
for the for the QC peptides and if we
now incorporate an exogenous spiked
peptides that is where we have
isotopically labeled peptide
and so now this controls for the loading
of the mass spectrometer and we ratio
the endogenous to the exogenous despite
peptides we see that those CVS can be
brought to less than five percent and so
that means that the robustness the
analytical robustness of the assay is
such that it could be a clinical
diagnostic assay and so the next slide
just shows a 99 peptides that are under
evaluation for around sixty biomarker
proteins that we're currently measuring
again over ninety six hours of runtime
so that's over four days of mass spec
runtime and for all 99 peptides the
average cv of all of the peptides not
removing any of them that are
uncomfortably have uncomfortability
large CV so this is an unbiased
assessment who shows that they have a
mean CV of 12% again demonstrating that
that's suitable for a clinical
diagnostic assay one of the questions
that's often asked is that of course
these assays take time each of the
assays in this occasion takes around 30
minutes and they run their run serially
one sample after the other so what we
did one on one occasion was just a count
up the number of samples that we'd run
in that small laboratory with a single
triple quad mass spectrometer over a
period of 28 days and this was just a
standard 28-day period in that
laboratory and we can see that the total
number of samples run on a single mass
spectrometer was around 1600 samples so
that's 1,600 samples 1300 of those were
patient samples and around 300 of them
worked quality control samples and so
that demonstrates I think that for one
instrument we could implement that at
this assay for all of the prostate
cancer patients in Ireland it gives you
I suppose a sense of the scale and the
realization that the throughput of a
mass spectrometer depending on the assay
and the clinical need of that assay
means that you could it could reliably
be used to measure and and assess
prostate cancer patients in this case so
the stage we're at at the moment is to
have taken that study further and and
subjected to an ongoing evaluation
that's been funded by Enterprise Ireland
in which we're measuring the panel of at
least 63 proteins
in 1500 patient samples evaluating the
analytical performance further and being
able to set the cost and the throughput
of that assay and then I suppose the
very next stage which is to evaluate the
the clinical that sorry the commercial
potential of the assay indeed how if we
divert this assay and it shows that it's
analytically and clinically robust
whether it can be brought to patient use
and and the reality is that to bring it
to patient use it would need to be
commercialized and so we need to
understand who's going to do that who's
going to pay for the tests
what regulatory path it may have to go
through and ultimately what healthcare
impact it would be likely to have and
this is where we spun out ature us to be
able to do that for the OSI Pro DX test
so that's really to be able to bring
this OSI pro DX test as we call it to
clinical use to take it to those next
stages of course we have the opportunity
then because this is a very flexible
mass spectrometry platform to develop
other tests and in the consideration for
doing that and funded through a horizon
2020 EU business development grant we've
established a business model in which
the patient sample is taken either in a
hospital or a phlebotomy department and
and that sample then is sent to the
laboratory in this case the Icarus
laboratory where the test is performed
on a triple quad mass spectrometer and
then the score which is obtained through
a proprietary algorithm is sent back to
the patient and the physician and so the
testing is done in a central centralized
laboratory and and so in the last few
weeks we've started the process of
developing that ature off centralized
laboratory and this just shows a picture
of the laboratory as it stands at the
moment about 12 weeks on from its from
its develop and you can see that this is
just a standard mass spectrometry
laboratory in which we have a number of
triple quad mass spectrometers there's
three in this sorry this two in this
picture and there are now as of
Monday last week three triple quad mass
spectrometers to be able to continue the
development of that that that workflow
one of the questions we often get asked
in developing this process is whether
these mrm essays give the same results
as Eliza's so whether if we were to
measure a protein by M R M whether it
would give the same result as a clinical
test performed in a clinical Diagnostics
laboratory and so that is whether M RN
is equivalent to Eliza and we could
spend a significant amount of time
debating whether that's absolutely
necessary but it does seem to be a
consideration that most people are a lot
of people places being one of very of
importance I'm not sure I share that
view but but nonetheless we were
recently asked to demonstrate it and so
in that new laboratory we developed an M
RM to a protein called c-reactive
protein and and we did that because we
had Eliza measurements that have been
undertaken on a a rush Diagnostics
platform in a series of patient samples
from patients not now with prostate
cancer but patients with surrounding
arthritis or rheumatoid arthritis and so
this just shows the results of a very
recent experiment in which an MRA meseta
CRP was developed over a three-day
period and that M R M then used to
measure CRP in 60 patient samples and
that data compared with the data from
Eliza's of those same 60 patient samples
and I think you can just about see here
that the correlation coefficients for
these mrm measurement and the Eliza
measurement are very similar indeed and
indeed when we look at the individual
patient samples and compare the PSA
patients with the RA patients whether
it's by Eliza or by M R M we see that we
get very similar statistically increased
CRP in the RA patients compared to the
PSA patients so I think the value in
this kind of data shows that in some
cases and indeed in this case the M R M
is entirely equivalent to analyzer the
difference of course is that this M R M
would took three days to develop
compared
to the time taken to develop analyzer
and of course what we were able to do
with the mrm is to multiplex it much
more effectively and so I think then to
summarize it I hope that's illustrated a
process that we have gone through to try
to develop a multiplex protein test for
prostate cancer and we have a number of
tests that we're developing and so if we
want to take biomarkers from something
we've discovered in the research
laboratory to a clinical test to a
diagnostic then I think it's evident
that the biomarker should be fit for the
purpose for which we intend it and of
course we need to know that purpose and
this reiterates the start at the end
principle the the MRC in reviewing the
process of generating Diagnostics from
biomarkers said that there needed to be
a process of reforming the regulatory
review process and one of the reasons
we've set up the odorous laboratory is
that at the moment these tests can be
undertaken in a central laboratory if
the sample is sent to that laboratory as
opposed to the tests being distributed
to hospital laboratories and it
suggested the LRC suggested that the
reimbursement of these tests needed to
be increased and clearly these are not
cheap tests necessarily but their value
lies in the savings that they provide to
the healthcare systems they're suggested
that they needed to be increased
investment in research to identify
better biomarkers moving forward there
needed to be increased rigor for the
assessment of biomarkers including
increased rigor in the publication of
biomarkers and one of George posts major
criticisms was that many of the
publications that have supposedly led to
the identity the identification of new
biomarkers have not themselves been
sufficiently robust and then of course
ultimately we need to adhere to a high
level evidence base if we're going to
recommend the use of these biomarkers
for making clinical decisions and that
really means that the tests have to have
analytical validity as well as clinical
value and of course they also are going
to require be required to have financial
value if they're going to be brought to
market so I think maybe a recipe for
success
and this is purposefully a question mark
because the jury I think is still out on
this is that we we need to identify
clinical need we have to start at the
end we then need to conceive a product
to fulfill that clinical need and that's
really important in our case once the
product was in for pro patients with
prostate cancer that define the required
three throughput and the speed with
which the tests needed to be performed
and that really does then revolve around
designing the tests to be fit for
purpose whether it's going to be point
of care or its undertaken in the
clinical laboratory it'll define the
turnaround time and the throughput
required and then we need to undertake a
process of evaluating the true clinical
value of the tests that we think we've
developed and in our case that's
something that's very much ongoing and
once passed that's been done or maybe
even before it's been done we need to
identify the monetary value of the test
and the reward and the route to which
it's going to be achieved and some would
argue that once all of that has been
theoretically undertaken then you can
begin the process I hope what I've been
able to illustrate in the brief time
that I presented this presentation is
that I firmly believe that targeted
proteomics methods these mrm methods
have utility for clinical tests that
ultimately there will be clinical tests
that developed that are written that
require mrm measurement of multiple
proteins it remains to me to acknowledge
the many individuals associated with the
work that we've been doing including
some from two individuals identified
from agilent technologies there are many
more members of my group but of course
most importantly the patients the
patients who've provided the samples to
enable us to do the discovery and the
evaluation studies and a whole team of
individuals ultimately we want to as
we've indicated move these tests forward
through Shiraz the company's small
company that we spun out and I suppose
the vision of the company is to deliver
diagnostic tests of global impact tests
that improve outcomes for patients and a
better financial situation for
healthcare systems that is a saving for
health care systems so with that I'll
end and I'll be very happy to take in
questions that you may have thank you
thank you doctor Pennington for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green to an A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window doctor Pennington will answer as
many questions as time permits and the
first question is is it necessary to
measure multiple transitions per peptide
and also doesn't quantification work
with the most intense transition yes
thank you thank you for that question
and it's a good question so
quantification does work with the most
intense transition and indeed there are
a number of papers that show that if you
measure the intense intense transition
versus measuring the three highest
intensity transitions the quantification
data is very similar so quantification
is done with the most intense transition
however we measure multiple transitions
per peptide because those are the those
transitions and the rank order of the
intensity of those transitions allows us
to determine whether the peptide and the
fragments generated from it are specific
to the peptide that we're attempting to
measure so they provide if you like a
quality assessment that the transitions
that we're measuring do indeed come from
the peptide that we're attempting to
measure do you include isotope labeled
peptides for each peptide you're
measuring at the moment we don't and
there's and I think there's ongoing
debate about whether this is whether
this is really necessary in many
instances in equivalent scenarios where
people are measuring for example
multiple messenger RNAs using reverse
transcriptase PCR they don't absolutely
quantify each of those those transcripts
instead they measure the relative levels
of the transcripts and use an algorithm
to derive a score or a numerical value
for the combination of them and I think
that's something that we anticipate will
be done in a similar fashion here that
we will measure the relative amounts of
those peptides and then using the
algorithm that we've developed produce a
score and it
be necessary to analytically measure and
quantify each of the peptides and
therefore we don't include isotope
labeled peptides is the test specific to
prostate cancer have you tested it
against other cancers and again that's
an interesting question and it's one
that we've we've given a significant
consideration to because what the test
isn't is a test that's used for the
diagnosis of prostate cancer it's a test
that you that's used subsequent to a
gold standard diagnosis of prostate
cancer which is a tissue biopsy so we
know that the test is only going to be
used in patients who have a diagnosis of
prostate cancer and that's what we
haven't tested whether it's whether it
measures or it is interfered with by
other cancers because we're assuming
because our men have been the men that
have been diagnosed with prostate cancer
have been very carefully clinically
evaluated that these are men who have
prostate cancer and not other tumors
there's the test work on plasma again a
good question and it's and this really
revolves around the difference between
plasma and serum and the challenges in
in using both of those those blood
matrices at the moment we are beginning
a process to evaluate whether the test
works on plasma there's a priori no
reason why it shouldn't but four
considerations they probably don't have
time to go into our preferred matrix has
always been serum and that as with all
of these things when you choose
something it has advantages and
limitations and of course the biggest
limitation with serum is that it
requires a blood draw and then
subsequent centrifuge centrifugation
which limits then the point of use of
the test so in this case the sample
that's used for the test has to be taken
in a clinic that has access to the
ability to prepare serum and so for
example using serum means that it could
never be a test at the moment could
be a test that could be done with a
blood draw at home whereas there's a
possibility that that would be the case
if it worked on plasma so at the moment
we're evaluating its ability to work on
plasma because that would increase the
number of sites at which the blood could
be used drawn for the use for that for
use for the test how efficient is
expression of a particular biomarker in
diagnosis of a specific cancer and can a
single biomarker be found in different
type carcinomas so I suppose that that
goes back to my question about that
diagnosis and so what we specifically
haven't attempted to do here is to
identify a protein that could be used to
diagnose the cancer I personally think
it's highly unlikely that a single
biomarker will be found that's specific
for particular cancers and and that rage
means that that because there are a
whole series of considerations the
expectation would be that that that
protein would have to be cancer specific
it would have to be a protein that's
produced in the cancer is created or
finds its way into the blood and then
could be measured at the level required
to be able to detect the tumor at an
early stage and I think that that's a
tall order for a single protein it's
probably even a tall order raised for a
number of different proteins and of
course if you're going to evaluate then
whether the protein or proteins really
are specific for a particular cancer
then the evaluation studies that need to
be performed need to rule out the
possibility that that protein also
identifies patients with other tumors
and so the samples then need to come
from patients who've got a range of
different tumors as well as obviously
healthy normal controls and that means
that the whole process of identifying a
protein that's a diagnostic biomarker
for a particular cancer is significantly
more challenging as we were waiting for
additional questions to come in I would
like to once again thank dr. Pennington
for his presentation
do you have any final comments sorry do
I have any final comments you'd like to
share and I suppose my final thought
that I'd a couple of thoughts the first
is that that I think it's becoming
apparent that these multiplexed mrm
measurements are being converted into
tests that's occurring as with many of
these molecular tests most most advances
being made in the area of cancer and so
there are mrm tests being developed for
lung cancer the prospect of these
multiplex tests being used as
laboratory-developed tests I think has
been improved significantly by a recent
ruling from the FDA saying that
multiplex mass spectrometry based tests
will be subject to phytate 510k
exemption and so that means that for the
regulatory process they can be advanced
and so I think that that the interest in
developing multiplex
tests for cancers is significant in our
own case we're also developing these as
alluded to previously in ceramic
arthritis and inflammatory conditions
and a number of other disease states so
I think they hold enormous potential for
the future thank you I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our educational sponsor agilent
technologies for today's webcast this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
February 2018 lab routes will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye